hey cousin I'm making this super easy
and delicious Shrimp Boat for dinner
today I'm working with a pound of peeled
jumbo shrimp by seasoning with Paprika
garlic powder black pepper a little salt
a little oil sauce to combine and I add
these to My Pan that's been heating on a
medium flame they cook three minutes
then you flip in another three minutes
in the same pan I browned some corn I
like it a little charred and I start
plating a bit of rice at the shrimp a
little pico de gallo the toasted corn I
opened up a mini avocado from Trader
Joe's and I'm on their good side again I
make a quick spicy mayo combined Mayo
Sriracha a little honey I make a
makeshift Piping Bag and I added to my
bowl and joy cousin